sometimes it's it's hard to break up
because it feels like you're giving them
exactly and that's what I never wanted
to do I he had doesn't you know so much
for me and was there for me at like one
of the hardest times in my life that to
me I just felt like how can I let this
go like that's how I looked at it the
last time we were trying is there's no
after everything he's done for me that
was my mentality at the time how can i
how can I leave him we have to figure it
out
so upon reflection after we I had the
day that he had told me he wanted a
divorce and I like how to break down and
then I went back to the house like a few
hours later and I was like okay like
let's okay I get it I agree I wanted to
be as amicable as possible because you
can get ugly fast and I didn't want that
and we were on the same page about that
but upon reflection with that I just I
don't know it was definitely for the
best and yeah Pam asked that's kind of
crazy cuz I can't imagine putting
yourself through that last few years
right because it's just it must be like
must feel like you're in limbo yes
because there's your twit this person
but you don't want to be but you should
because you have this certain sense of
loyalty because of what he helped you
through in the past so you're just going
back and forth constantly how do you how
do you deal with that [ __ ] cuz I'm a
very just kind of like just you know
isn't that I didn't want to be with him
it was more like I was like how much can
I deal with like you know he's he
parties a lot so it was like how much
like for instance like that's like one
example of like something one of our
huge differences so like how much can I
deal with that like I need to just
accept that this is a part of who he is
and and and stop fighting against it but
at a certain point you make allowances
that go against your value system and I
think that's where I was struggling the
most and it wasn't fun like it wasn't
it's weird
like you're its you we would didn't
there wasn't a lot of great
communication towards the end or any
really there was a lot of you know
contempt which is really unhealthy and
there's a there's a hard part right
there too because I just talked to a
friend yesterday over here mister
counselor but I just talked to a friend
yesterday because she split up with his
girlfriend right and you know typically
what happens is when you go through
these conversations they'll say things
and you kind of pick apart what they're
saying right so he mentioned something
along the lines of his girlfriend she
likes to party a lot and he mentioned a
couple times he goes but it doesn't
bother me and as long as I can do within
this conversation you mentioned a few
times that she goes out partying and it
doesn't bother you if it didn't bother
you would have never mentioned it to me
it does bother you yeah and I was like
the the problem is is that you I think
he doesn't want to be the controlling
boyfriend right he doesn't want to be
put in that light and he doesn't want to
give that reason to them to throw it
back in his face so for him it's like oh
no I'm cool with it but I was like see
you're not cool with it though that's
something that's fundamentally something
that bothered that isn't who you are
you're not a partying person you don't
like the people that she hangs out with
you don't like this stuff this is
something that you should be able to
discuss openly and if it's a breaking
point for you there's no way that you're
gonna be able to swallow this big pill
every [ __ ] no so it kind of came to
head for him yeah and he's gonna go back
and talk to her about it yeah because it
does bother him because I guess for her
she kind of travels and does her own
thing without him with her own bunch of
friends he says it's not really her
friends that's like her party friends
and so he goes I don't even know them
they're not really your friends you're
going out on these trips that you're not
even paying for who's paying for these
trips and I'm just supposed to be okay
with it he goes yeah I guess I'm okay no
it's never I guess I'm okay
are you okay with it or are you not yeah
that's it that's what I mean when I say
like when you get into a relationship
you make allowances because you you're
their [ __ ] completely different human
being than you so what are you okay with
what are you not okay with and at a
certain point sometimes before you've
done a lot of work on yourself I think
you people tend to make allowances for
certain behaviors or
patterns that go against their value
system but they're not able to really
register that that's what's happening
until you're a year down the line and
it's eating at you you know it takes
time for those things to to have the
effect that it will eventually have on
you and by that point you're this far
along into the relationship so it's like
how am I going to [ __ ] give this up
now
why not put more work into it but that's
why I think it's so important to have
done the work on yourself yeah before
entering a relationship so that you can
know what you're ok with and what you're
not ok with at the at the base level of
who you're bringing into your life and
yeah yeah for sure I call those things
how I describe it to people I always ask
them I was like what are your pillars
and they go well we're two pillars I was
like pillars other things that hold up
your foundation those things should
never shift right and if they if they
shift that foundation then that might be
something that you can't really
compromise for I was like find out what
what are the things that you will never
compromise for yeah and for me I have
those things she never touches those
things were completely fine right other
than that everything else is just
fighting arguments and bickering but the
fundamental basics of who I am are not
touched and then she respects that and
she loved those parts about me then
generally I think that you anybody will
be okay yeah right and so for him in his
case was he wants to be with somebody
that likes to share life experiences
with him that they're allowed to have
separate friends and he wants her to
have friends and go out but when it
comes to traveling and those the free
time he would like for her to spend that
with him just so they could develop that
part he wants somebody to travel with
yeah and all the time that she's
traveling it's not with him and he's
waiting at home and it's like well
that's something that you want that's a
big [ __ ] thing it was a big thing for
someone like him yeah who wants who
that's like a part of it's like the
opposite of why exactly he's just like
no I think I'm okay you're not okay with
it dude if you say you think you're okay
like you're not okay there's
only things that I like she knows for me
it's like there's like definites that I
have that she for me like for example
even though it may not seem I'm hyper
religious but like I do want to have
somebody with Christian values even if
let's say later on the lives like I
don't really like going to church I like
Christian values a lot I think that's
always you might have a shot somebody so
I like for me is you know I'm like I I
think Jesus helps me out a bit so I
think I would like for my kids to have a
little Jesus in their lives you know why
the [ __ ] not so the kid could figure out
if he wants Jesus in his life later on
yeah that's all up to him but I don't
want to at least instill those Christian
values because just for me growing up I
know a lot of dudes that were pieces of
[ __ ] and they don't believe in God now
but they kept a lot of their Christian
values you know loyalty community having
open communication not being afraid to
show love and I learned a lot of that
from church so I think that's what I
really enjoy about it so that's
definitely one number two is a strong
family ties is really understanding how
important family is
yeah because if you can't be respectful
to your parents you're not gonna be
respectful to mine and you're not gonna
be our relationship might be a little
off because I think as I got older when
I was younger I remember my dad told me
he goes you need to be with somebody
that understands what a good family is
and my mind I'm like - you just don't
like broken people huh you're [ __ ]
judgmental [ __ ] you no that's what I
would say to him and as I get older I
start to realize that there are things
that happens to somebody at a young age
that they don't know how to address and
they don't realize how it affects him as
an adult that's basically what my dad
was saying he just said it in a very
terrible way and I'm starting to find
that out now a lot of my friends who do
come from broken homes not just broken
homes just terrible situations growing
up it affects them as an adult and they
can't they can't see it but everybody
else does by being in a family sometimes
where and you know like I said if you
don't grow up with like two parents in
the household but if you see a healthy
relationship from your uncle your aunt
there's a there are those but there's
some people who just don't see any of
that [ __ ] they don't see it from close
siblings like their uncles aunts their
cousins or whatever and they don't know
what that healthy relationship is I've
seen a lot of my female friends yeah who
have this certain perception of what men
like male machismo is like what a man
should
and they think this is my case once
again my personal friends they're like I
want somebody to always take care of me
guys have to do this this is what a man
is but who what what are you basing that
on who was that who was the man in your
life in your household that showed you
that this was a man was or is and that's
just like a reoccurring theme that I see
a lot yeah or a thought the kid without
a mom they don't understand how to
nurtured they don't know how to be
emotionally available because the dad
was the tough guy yeah everything is I
have to be tough I can't cry [ __ ] your
feelings I think the it's possible
because I could come from like us very
broken like family situation I really
didn't realize it I mean it's definitely
possible to come from that and then work
on it sure come out as long as you
recognize it but you have to recognize
yeah I think that was like a huge in the
end when I look back on the my marriage
like that that whole relationship it now
is a huge mirror back to me as far as
like what I needed to work on and the
effects that all of my past and
childhood and stuff was having on me and
in a completely negative way and what I
was the things I would wouldn't take
responsibility for and so since then
putting the focus back of myself I think
I actually started that after we had
gotten separated yeah when I went into
therapy that it takes a lot of work but
it's possible for someone to come from
that situation
and then kind of turn it around Oh a
hundred percent it's a [ __ ] lot of
work and it's really hard yeah and I
think the biggest difference is that you
you recognize it right and just like
anybody else as long as you recognize
your faults there's a possibility that
you can work on it yeah I think with a
few people that I know it's it's hard
for me to bring it up to them and if I
do I'm the enemy so I just don't even
touch it it's like what's the whole
point like if I if I tell you like hey
you're I think as a friend that what's
happening here with your relationship is
that you have a very skewed persecute
perspective of what a man or a woman
should be in a relationship and it might
be because you had a really rough life
and your dad
from that and people are paying for the
stuff that you paid for as a kid mm-hmm
and that stuff constantly projects out
people don't even [ __ ] know it like
when I when I first started going out
with Muriel she had this thing where she
didn't know how to express her anger and
it used to piss me the [ __ ] off because
it comes out passive-aggressively
I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] because I'm
expressive right so if I'm upset I try
to figure out how to say it sometimes it
may not come out in the best way
but I'm always honest with my feelings
yeah uh she's not like that anymore
she's a little too expressive I open a
Pandora's box and I [ __ ] up so now so
I remember this is like a very specific
example she would do some [ __ ] that
would piss me off because I could tell
that she's clearly upset right yeah she
would do this [ __ ] where I would be
asking her hey I know you're upset she
goes oh I'm not upset would you say it
like that my blood boils like a kettle
was put in the center of the Sun I was
I'm like okay when you say it like that
you're starting I'm not mad at all are
you mad
where's it where's the rifle I'm gonna
shoot this woman in the [ __ ] face and
I might listen when you're upset it's
okay we just gotta talk about be upset
she goes
I'm not mad and then and then she's like
passing but she all but okay we'll pass
the salt right and then she just and
slide it over I'm like oh you're not mad
you just took all the lacquer off the
[ __ ] table
when you slid that little salt pepper
shakers thank you son-of-a-bitch
and so she'll get she'd just do a
passive-aggressive [ __ ] like that and
her anger would come out this way and I
remember at one time we were in the car
and we went on a hike and this is
something that I really hated about her
early on was that she would do things
she was such an independent woman she
would just do everything everything on
her own accord and not wait for me
so firaon aha if we're hiking she would
walk like a thousand paces ahead of me
and we're supposed to hike together and
mind you I was [ __ ] fat I mean leave
no fat man behind I think that was in
the Bible and so I'm just trailing
behind her and then she's just cool with
it I'm like yo I want you to walk at my
pace like walk at my pace and I got
[ __ ] pissed and then we're in the car
I was like you're upset because of what
I said she goes I'm
mad not mine dude when you're I was like
if you're I'm mad now I'm like if you're
[ __ ] mad just say you're mad
she turns at me and this is the center
console of the car she goes boom boom
boom do you and I looked at I said oh my
bad oh [ __ ] my bad uh I didn't I didn't
mean okay I don't know it was like ever
since then she's been hyper expressive
and I regret that moment till this day
but the funny thing is I and all jokes
aside I rather have that than having to
deal with a pissy ass person for the
whole day is so unhealthy and that's how
I that was like one of my many flaws and
my loss really the in my marriage like
that was it was now when I think about
it I'm mortified about the new face to
do I mean I've worked on it and it's
very not really there and I know how to
catch it and yeah and hold myself
responsible in the moment to kind of get
out of whatever pattern or behavior I'm
getting into but that shit's like it's
super and it's unbelievably unhealthy to
be passive-aggressive oh for sure
like communication is always key just
learning how to talk things out and
there's this balance that sometimes
people forget of how to be really
affirmative with their words without
being aggressive yeah yeah and also
Express communicating without assigning
meaning to because when someone upsets
you and you're trying to communicate
what's going on for you with you have to
do it without assigning meaning to their
behavior suck at that [ __ ] it's
because you know why would you [ __ ]
do it [ __ ] asses ask questions like
it's a command I don't even know how you
do it it's like oh so you're just gonna
leave the garbage there that's right
hold on a second are you asking me to
take out the trash are you trying to
fistfight me right now cuz I will
[ __ ] we will put on gloves and we'll
go
that's how Muriel does [ __ ] she goes oh
so we're just going to leave the air
conditioning on all day that's cool
are you what is this what is going on
here just tell me to turn it off
pretty much good to go girls are so good
at that [ __ ] and it just gets under my
oh it's annoying it should be on your
scan that's annoying oh she's so cute
and I'm just like oh dude but we she
still does that till this day
like it just bothers me but then I
always joke about it so we say something
in the moment or like do you like
snapback no now it just turns into jokes
because it's not it's not enough to get
me actually angry anymore so I like she
just did that yesterday should we I
forgot oh she had a dream this is this
is some crazy she got mad at me so I
couldn't figure out why she was so mad
at me I might what the [ __ ] did I do I
just woke up like I literally just
breathed life two seconds ago well how
can I be what have I done you felt you
said what have I done
but she was cleaning up the house and
you know it was something small where
she goes she looks at me and she goes so
you use two cups mmm there's some
meaning behind that I'm like yeah I just
used 2 cups she goes cool could you try
after you're done using your cups to put
it in the dishwasher I'm like oh she
trying to get socked what did I do and
then you know just joking around I'd
look at em joking around like hey you
don't [ __ ] talk to me like that woman
you know I'm being cute and joking about
it and she goes no you Paul Gees put
away your cups and I'm like that's
[ __ ] right I'm like we're gonna take
it outside and then she goes oh I had a
terrible dream I'm like that's it I knew
it there's something wrong she had a
dream that I was pregnant and I was
gonna give birth and she wasn't ready to
have a child but I was ready to have it
that's why she was mad at me because I
was pregnant in her dream something
that's not [ __ ] physically possible
she was mad at me for forgetting knocked
up [ __ ] who knocked me up you did that
dream you're the one who stuck your
dirty penis inside my butt